I cook that's what I do it the process
of cooking is the process by which
nature is transformed into culture I'm
working to try to loosen the connection
between religious traditions and their
kind of tribal tweedle dogmatic function
free-software movement
neuroendocrinology reporter empirical
viewpoint looking at a different way
very large messy complicated problems
it's just ludicrous for journalists to
say I don't have an opinion we all have
opinions we're all dripping with opinion
how are we gonna manage you keep stable
a global financial system with the
world's greatest borrower being the
world's greatest power young people
ordinary culture health care delivery
those who condone the attacks and say
that they are justified don't cite
religion at all they actually cite
political grievances while I often
describe myself as Prince's greatest fan
I also think fundamentally I have to be
its greatest critic secular
fundamentalist Linux and Apache PHP Perl
you have a thought or feeling or an
emotion or an idea you make a very
specific chemical it's called a
neuropeptide I should go to the library
and look that up but I mean frankly
nobody ever must went to the library to
look things up